in. >> That's good David, and to builder's example, what do we actually do,
when we have to? Plan a navigation route to go from one location,
to another location, in an urban area. We use knowledge of the goal.
The goal tells us, what turn to take at every intersection? We want to take
a turn, that helps us get closer to the goal. So one thing we are learning here,
is there are different kinds of knowledge. There is knowledge about the world,
the intersections and the turns, the states and the operators more generally.
There's also asset knowledge about how to do the operator selection, how to
select between greatest terms at any intersection? This knowledge is tacit, and
is sometimes called control knowledge. Goals provide us with the control
knowledge, of deciding how to select between different operators. Let us
recall how means-end analysis work. How goals poetic control knowledge, and
means-end analysis heuristic method, if you would compare the Current State and
the Goal State and enumerate the differences between them.
Then we'll select the operator that will help us reduce,
the largest difference within the Current State and the Goal State. That's one,
way of using goals as control knowledge to select between operators. Planning,
provides more system mathematics matters for selecting between different
operators. So the real problem now becomes, how to do operator selection,
which is the same problem as, how to do action selection. Recall with me,
we're talking about intelligent agents. We define intelligent agents,
as agents that map perceptual history into actions.
Action selection was a key problem, was a central problem. This is
where planning is central, because it deals starkly with action selection, or
with operator selection. Operators simply mental representations of actions,
that we live with in the world. So, let us look at what a plan might look like,
in the language we have been developing for
planning. A plan might look like this, here is the Initial State, and
a set of successor states. A series of states, punctuated by an operators
that transform one state into another. Here we have expanded this operative,
paint ceiling, to specify its peak conditions and post conditions, and there's
several things not worthy here. Note that the preconditions of this operator,
exactly match the predecessor's state. So, we have on robot ladder, here,
and we have on robot ladder, here. So, some assertions of the world are true,
here. And those assertions match the precondition,
which is why this operator is applicable. Similarly, the post conditions of this
operator, directly match the assertions about the world in this successor state.
So I have painted ceiling here, there is painted ceiling there.
There is not dry ceiling here, there is not dry ceiling here.
So this provides a very precise way, of specifying the states, and
the operators, and t he exact connections between them.